MARIA: WELCOME BACK.
HERE IS A PICTURE OF THE NORMAL
LY BUSY STREETS IN
ATLANTA NOW NEARLY DESSERTED AS
GEORGIA’S GOVERNOR ORDERS THE
STATE TO SHELTER IN PLACE
AMID THE CORN PANDEMIC.
JOINING ME IS GEORGIA
CONGRESSMAN DOUG COLLINS THE
RANKING REPUBLICAN ON THE
HOUSE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
AND CONGRESSMAN ALWAYS A
PLEASURE TO SEE YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR BEING HERE.
>> GOOD MORNING, MARIA.
MARIA: WAS IT TOO LITTLE TOO
LATE IN TERMS OF A STAY IN PLACE
ORDER IN GEORGIA, JUST FRIDAY?
>> YEAH, NO I DON’T THINK SO.
I THINK IT WAS COMING.
REMEMBER WE HAD A LOT OF OUR
LOCAL COUNTIES, MUNICIPALITIES
THAT HAD ALREADY BEEN TAKING
THIS LEAVE AND THE .
>> GOVERNOR: UNDER HAD BEEN
WATCHING THAT AND NOW IT CONFIRM
S IT ALL OVER THE STATE.
WE ARE TOUGH AND WE’RE MAKING
HEAD WAY INTO IT.
IT’S STILL VERY ACTIVE IN
CERTAIN AREAS, BUT I’M CONFIDENT
OUR HOSPITALS, OUR LOCAL
OFFICIALS WILL CONTINUE TO AND
STATE OFFICIALS WILL KEEP DOING
THEIR JOB.
MARIA: SO CONGRESSMAN YOU HAVE
BEEN REALLY SHOWING SUCH
LEADERSHIP ON YOUR COMMITTEE,
JUDICIARY, AND OF COURSE, BEEN
DEALING WITH A LOT OF BACK AND
FORTH WITH YOUR COLLEAGUES ON
THE LEFT.
NOW, THE SPEAKER, NANCY PELOSI,
SAYS SHE WANTS TO INVESTIGATE
PRESIDENT TRUMP AGAIN.
THIS TIME SHE’S GOING TO CREATE
A COMMISSION TO INVESTIGATE THE
ADMINISTRATIONS COVID-19
RESPONSE.
ADAM SCHIFF IS PROPOSING A
SEPARATE 9/11-STYLE COMMISSION
WITH SUBPOENA POWER, THEY WANT
MORE SUBPOENA POWER HERE, ON
THESE COMMISSIONS.
YOU’RE REACTION, IS THIS WHAT’S
GOING ON NOW IN TERMS OF YOUR
COMMITTEE?
>> YOU KNOW IF THERE WAS A
POSSIBILITY, I KEEP MY HAIR
SHORT IN CONGRESS, MARIA, NOT
PULL IT OUT BECAUSE EVERY TIME
WE TURN AROUND SPEAKER PELOSI,
ADAM SCHIFF, ALL THEY WANT TO DO
IS TAKE ANY ENVIRONMENT THEY CAN
AND TURN IT TO ATTACK THE
PRESIDENT.
THE PRESIDENT IS DOING A GOOD
JOB, THE PRESIDENT IS WORKING
HARD, HE’S ON TV EVERY DAY,
TALKING TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
EVERY DAY, HE’S GOT HIS VICE
PRESIDENT LEADING THE TASK FORCE
, ALL THESE LEADERS LEADING
AND WHAT DO WE HEAR FROM SPEAKER
PELOSI AND NOW ADAM SCHIFF IS
THEY WANT TO HAVE THESE
COMMISSIONS OR  THESE 9/11
COMMISSIONS TO INVESTIGATE THE
PRESIDENT.
ALL THEY’VE EVER DONE IS SORT OF
AMAZING I HEARD A QUOTE
YESTERDAY FROM SPEAKER PELOSI I
THINK SHE SAID WHEREVER THERE’S
MONEY THERE’S MISS CHEF.
THAT’S PRETTY RICH COMING FROM
THE SPEAKER WHOSE THE PIED PIPER
WHO TRIED TO PUT EVERYTHING INTO
THIS BILL AND WORRIED ABOUT
WHERE IT’S GOING NOW.
WHY DON’T WE FOCUS ON HELPING
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, DO LIKE THE
PRESIDENT HAS ASKED LET’S
GET THE M IN TO WHERE IT NEEDS
TO GO AND HELP OUR HEALTHCARE
OFFICIALS AND HELP OUR HOSPITALS
AND HELP BUSINESSES GET BACK TO
WORK JUST LIKE YOU’VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT ON THE SHOW THIS
MORNING THIS IS SOMETHING
WE’VE GOT TO GET THROUGH AND
THEN RECOVER FROM, AND JUST TO
SIMPLY DO THIS NOT TO ATTACK AND
BASICALLY SAY WE’RE GOING TO
FOLLOW THIS PRESIDENT IS JUST
RANDOMLY WHAT WE’VE SEEN THE
LAST YEAR AND A HALF.